boa tarde pessoal
é uma felicidade muito grande poder
estar aqui nesta tarde de maravilhosa
compartilhando com tantas pessoas
diferentes nesta vamos comentando sobre
a diversidade dessa platéia hoje e
dialogando sobre um tema tão importante
que é esse imenso campo de
possibilidades que se chama futuro é meu
nome é ana flávia maria que eu sou
brasileira
sou mulher sou mãe sot cidadã professora
sua pesquisadora e eu mantenho minhas
mãos pés e coração assentados no campo
das ciências ambientais é eu preciso
compartilhar com vocês antes de qualquer
coisa eu acredito profundamente nas
forças revolucionárias da paz e da
justiça para a construção desse mundo
novo que nós todos desejamos que mudança
queremos o que mudanças queremos o tema
que nos une
falando sobre diversas questões
importantes contemporaneamente é isso né
que mudança todos nós desejamos é e
quando a gente fala que mudança nós
desejamos nós estamos nos colocando no
papel de atores dessas mudanças e isso
não pode nos escapar jamais nós não
somos observadores do processo
nós somos atores da mudança construtores
do futuro e paulo freire nos diz lá na
sua pedagogia da autonomia algo que me
toca e me move m
enfim desafia seguir nesse campo
ele nos diz que o futuro ele não é algo
dado mas ele é um desafio e é nesse
campo do desafio
o que eu tenho desenvolvido há pesquisas
na área da justiça ambiental
nós todos sabemos e é um dos motes para
estarmos reunidos aqui hoje que vivemos
um momento de crise é uma crise mundial
e é uma crise multifacetada
algumas pessoas tentam definir lá como
crise econômica à crise política enfim
mas ela é uma crise de distintas ordens
do meio ambiente é palco dessa crise que
permeia contemporaneidade
isso porque o planeta terra e hoje mais
do que nunca se fica evidente para todos
nós
ficou evidente na fala dos meus colegas
que me antecederam ele foi rasgado em
nacos foi dividido em ações separadas em
territórios dissecado em forma de
recursos que são distribuídos
desigualmente entre os povos humanos
os desastres ditos naturais assolam a
nossa sociedade
contemporaneamente de uma maneira talvez
inesperada quando os pesquisadores há um
tempo atrás falavam década de 90
falavam sobre mudanças climáticas nós
não acreditávamos ou fomos levados a não
acreditar que esse discurso fosse tão
sério né e hoje na verdade percebemos
que as perspectivas daqueles
pesquisadores foram até o time misto
diante do que tem acontecido
contemporaneamente e estes desastres
ditos naturais também não atingem as
populações humanas de forma igual né
nós percebemos que a parcela da
população humana marginalizada seja
porque a detentora das menores rendas
seja por questões étnicas e outras
diferenças acaba sendo atingida mais
fortemente pelos danos ambientais
essa percepção ela chegou na população
negra norte americana na década de 60 e
foi lá que foi cunhado o termo justiça
ambiental pela primeira vez e passou a
ser utilizado então enfim por todos nós
apropriado em diversas escalas
né porque nós precisamos de precisamos
falar de justiça ambiental
em primeiro lugar porque os desastres
ditos naturais não são naturais e essa
percepção ela precisa ficar muito clara
eles são resultado de um processo de
apropriação exploração da natureza que
foi transformado em recursos como a
gente estava falando anteriormente é e
que foi decidida por parcela da
população humana mas cujos efeitos
acabam atingindo é de diferentes formas
a população ea gente é levado a
acreditar que esses desastres são
naturais que as pessoas estão morando em
áreas de deslizamento porque é natural
que elas estejam lá que as pessoas estão
perdendo nas inundações seus sonhos
juntamente com seus bens materiais e que
isso é natural
nós crescemos e evoluímos neste planeta
terra animais humanos demais grupos
animais espécies vegetais demais grupos
é com quem dividimos o planeta terra
nós evoluímos e chegamos a esse ponto
porque participamos num processo
conhecido como co evolução evoluímos
juntos
crescemos juntos o planeta terra nos
forneceu recursos suficientes e e
gratuitos para que chegássemos onde
chegamos atualmente até que o homo
sapiens sapiens decidiu tomar algumas
atitudes voltadas para um processo de
ser muito diferente do que o ser
biológico e cultural e aí nós criamos as
diferenças e os resultados dessas
diferenças
então aí expressos nos nossos
territórios
quando nós começamos a pensar e justiça
ambiental nesses termos então começamos
a pensar justiça porque na verdade nos
deparamos com a injustiça né eu olhar
sobre a injustiça ele pode se dar em
qualquer escala do território né
em 2012 mais ou menos nós iniciamos um
trabalho é uma pesquisa não é tentando
entender como é que é e como é que as
injustiças ambientais especializavam a
nossa cidade
em santa cruz do sul né cidade que está
na porção central do estado do rio
grande do sul no vale do rio pardo no
chamado vale do rio pardo é uma cidade
caracterizada pelo adensamento urbano em
razão das instituições de ensino
especialmente do complexo agroindustrial
do fumo
lançamos o nosso olhar para santa cruz
do sul
vamos discutir justiça ambiental ou
injustiça ambiental em santa cruz do sul
qual é o nosso primeiro desafio
definirmos aqui o que nós entendemos por
justiça
e aí nós nos deparamos então com o
pensamento do professor a marcha ceni
que fala aqui eu já mudei o slide para a
gente observar essa foto aqui pra gente
pensar ananás conceituações do professor
a marte no contexto da vida real em
santa cruz do sul né
a professora maria tv dizer que nós
cruzeiro ditos induz o termo justiça ele
pode ser entendido de duas formas
diferentes em sentido lato significam a
mesma coisa mas na prática existem
diferenças importantes nip ine a nike se
refere à justiça institucionalizada em
códigos normas e regulamentações n área
é a justiça é aplicada na vida prática
dos seres humanos das populações humanas
né
a foto que a gente está vendo aqui
ela mostra a 4 dos meus heróis
essa foto foi tirada em 2012 no bairro
margarida na zona sul da cidade de santa
cruz do sul
nós tínhamos um trabalho de extensão da
nossa universidade que se caracteriza
como uma universidade comunitária né e
enchem baseia grande parte das suas
ações nesse trabalho de interação com as
comunidades
e enfim trabalhar vamos com esse grupo
da associação de moradores do bairro
margarida discutindo porque o bairro
margarida ele tem casas que estão
localizadas na parte baixa do bairro e
residências enfim populações que estão
habitando as encostas de morro né
são costas de coluna e que já apresenta
uma fragilidade ambiental por si só a
gente observa aqui nesse na imagem ela
simboliza muito da minha crença na
transformação de nick ine área da
justiça que está nos nossos códigos na
justiça aplicada a nossa vida prática
porque essas pessoas esses heróis dos
quais eu falo para vocês estão
aparecendo na foto eles sabem que eles
são atores da construção do seu futuro e
eles aceitam esse papel
tomaram esse papel para si nos reunimos
todas as terças-feiras de noite e saímos
para algumas excursões durante o dia
para visitarmos essas áreas de
fragilidade que estão nos nos morros do
cinturão verde de santa cruz do sul né
então aí vocês estão vendo na foto nós
estamos na foto seus l da veiga de verde
que era o presidente da associação de
moradores do bairro margarida sendo
auxiliado pelo seu aloisi seguido pela
rosane pelo rogério é ele estão
transpondo um obstáculo natural em uma
área de inundação e eles estão
exercitando algo que é muito básico
quando a gente fala de justiça ambiental
a transição de nacionalidades de uma
racionalidade é extremamente assentada
no capital que constrói nossos
territórios de acordo com os interesses
do capital ea chamada racionalidade
ambiental que parte da ideia de co
geração dos conceitos de habitat de
resiliência de permanência de com
evolução que era aquilo que falamos
rapidamente anteriormente
a idéia de discutir justiça ambiental
passa pela compreensão de que os
territórios são construções só as
históricas que se dão sobre bases
naturais e eles têm a cara que nós
sociedade e desejamos dar a eles qual é
a cara que nós desejamos dar para os
nossos territórios
contemporaneamente quais são os nossos
desejos especializados dos nossos
territórios
começamos esse trabalho então em
princípio com a associação de moradores
do do bairro margarida no bairro
margarida nós trabalhamos efetivamente
conhecendo bairro passeando pelas ruas
do bairro conhecendo os grupos de
moradores que habitam nos diferentes
territórios no bairro e depois
estendemos a pesquisa para a área urbana
de santa cruz do sul como um todo e aí
nós utilizamos a metodologia que o
professor erre axel rádio e sua equipe
utilizaram para estudar o estado do rio
de janeiro nem isso em 2002 no ano de
fizemos um recorte temporal de dez anos
de 2004 e 2004 torezin
e identificamos né diagnosticamos
analisamos e classificamos dentro dessas
quatro classes que podemos observar que
na imagem os conflitos ambientais que
foi que apareceram no jornal local the
de maior circulação aqui em santa cruz
do sul
identificamos então um total de 376
conflitos categorizados de acordo com a
natureza do fato desencadeante nas
classes que podemos observar aqui
disposição de lixo e resíduos
loteamentos em áreas de risco áreas
protegidas atividades industriais é a
ausência de saneamento
depois nós pegamos então esses conflitos
que foram identificados e localizamos
mapeamos né
temos cartas temáticas
vamos assim para localizar os conflitos
no espaço utilizamos um buffer sozinho
ali um alargamento nas nos círculos que
vocês podem ver na imagem para mostrar
as áreas onde havia maior incidência dos
conflitos que nós encontramos no jornal
local que se entende por conflitos sócio
ambiental diferentes interesses no uso
dos espaços né
o meio ambiente o território é que o
meio à natureza apropriada transformada
que recebe as instituições humanas
ele é um campo de forças e nesse campo
de forças a gente observa a a disputa
entre as idéias de planejamento
as diferenças políticas e as diferenças
sociais
então aqui a gente pode ver a primeira
classe disposição inadequada de resíduos
de suas compras seus conseqüentes
impactos localizada nas nos mapas
temáticos são cartas com finalidade
meramente ilustrativa né loteamentos em
áreas de risco e protegida que geram
enchentes deslizamentos de terras e
moradias em áreas frágeis a especulação
imobiliária privatização de áreas verdes
que a gente encontra muito nosso na área
urbana de santa cruz do sul
os desastres dito naturais e residências
frágeis eu gostaria muito que chama
atenção para as imagens estão postas
aqui na verdade são duas imagens né
na imagem superior a gente observa as
construções no cinturão verde na área de
preservação permanente e em baixo a
gente tem uma imagem que mostra se vocês
observarem bem uma residência que está
apoiada em pedras né de uma maneira
muito frágil na maior parte das vezes
não está aparecendo aqui nas imagens nós
temos auto construções são frágeis e não
resistem aos eventos ambientais
então se uma casa de auto-construção uma
residência extremamente frágil é for
levada por uma enxurrada isso não é um
desastre natural
embora não sejamos levados a acreditar
que há conflitos gerados por atividades
industriais e por ausência
aqui nós temos novamente os meus heróis
e mais alguns outros tantos que
participaram dos projetos de cartografia
social no bairro margarida que
participaram dos projetos de construção
de hortas comunitárias
é enfim se tornar um sujeito do seu
processo de desenvolvimento
a idéia do trabalho com justiça
ambiental s/a que as pessoas se
apercebam como participantes do projeto
do processo de injustiça ou vítimas do
processo de injustiça mas que a partir
daí assumiu para si a possibilidade de
transformação da sua realidade
então diante desse contexto de crise é
de impactos de toda ordem distribuídos
igualmente entre as populações humanas e
finaliza a minha fala deixando a algumas
o uma questão básica enfim para a gente
refletir sobre o tema né
nós sempre como comunidade humanos
estamos pensando no tempo
será que o tempo será que o tempo da
mudança é agora será que o tempo da
mudança já passou
andré que nós devemos falar de justiça
ambiental
quando falamos do vento e do frio e do
calor
quando falamos do petróleo e da produção
de alimentos de terras que desmoronam de
rios que cercam as espécies que deixam
de existir quando falamos de mosquitos e
doenças e curas vacinas e venenos
quando falamos de mudanças climáticas
quando falamos dos filhos dos nossos
filhos do medo da concentração de renda
e das injustiças de toda hora
e aí eu gostaria de finalizar não
utilizando das lindas palavras da
carentes é que discutir justiça
carcerária mas que compartilhamos a
nossa perspectiva de criar uma sociedade
justa 47 anos diz
lembremos que estamos todos conectados
mistério em
lamento a esse universo ao planeta terra
e uns aos outros
gratidão imensa na máscara
[Aplausos]